I don't even notice as you notice that
everyone right now in public life is
apologizing pretty much 20 pretty much
24/7 right
everyone's apart the governor of
Virginia apologized in the Attorney
General of Virginia apologizing actors
apology everyone's coming out and
apologizing and I thought I should start
tonight's show by just coming clean
they've dug up some embarrassing footage
of me yeah
it's every episode of my show over the
last 25 years I just want to say I'm
sorry it was a crazy time back then yeah
93 1993 to 2019 you guys don't know you
weren't there that was a crazy crazy
time things were very different things
were very dairy and they are it was all
Mountain fun I think about that every
now and then just 20s it's almost like
25 years over 25 years 26 years of just
total [ __ ] or ego that's why I can't
be a governor you know well that Andy
incompetent oh we're gonna talk about
the incompetence are we let's leave out
the incompetence it's crazy though in
Virginia the top three government
officials are embroiled in scandal and
if all three did you know this if all
three stepped down you know what happens
Liam Neeson becomes governor Virginia is
a weird state it's a really really
strange state it's it's in there it's in
the Constitution it goes back to 1788
yeah I named Northern Irish actor she'll
take over it's really crazy what's
happening in Virginia right now first
the governor was asked to resign after
photos surfaced allegedly showing him in
blackface then the second in line the
lieutenant governor was accused of
sexual assault then Virginia's third in
charge the Attorney General admitted to
also wearing blackface in college yes
those Woo's are too good
it's like we hired actor well you're
pretty good at that you want to come on
Conan yeah but the point is they know
blackface is bad yeah yeah it hurts it's
like this is a children show yeah now
remember if Conan mentions blackface co
Oh anyway the top three are all in a
scandal everyone's apologizing it's
getting crazy right now it's it's
getting worse actually there's a press
conference going on at the Virginia
State Capitol building at this very
moment and it's getting out of control
take a look black face black face black
face three black faces a couple of
gropes and a home invasion thank you I
was a member of Isis summer of 2012
I shot Tupac I have a girls volleyball
team in my basement I made one of those
human centipedes public masturbation
once in college and once right now I
operate a Fight Club for little people I
do as well
[Applause]